here's another quick tutorial on how to
quickly ruin your life Step 1 eliminate
your goals don't Orient yourself towards
a North star don't develop a vision for
what your life could be like doing this
will make it impossible to progress in
life because without a goal how do you
know you're progressing eliminate any
desire to get yourself out of a
sub-optimal situation subscribe to the
idea that this is just the way life is
this is all I can be it's not
hopelessness it's self-acceptance use
loving yourself as an excuse to spin
your wheels and mentally deteriorate
confuse self-love with self-neglect
wander aimlessly through life not really
knowing why you're here step two stay
inside don't expose yourself to the
light don't be a person in the world
stay hidden operate in the shadows never
subject yourself to the Judgment of
others close yourself off from new info
and New Perspectives let algorithms
create deep grooves of repeated behavior
and topics catering only to your already
limited interests until you're viewing
the same things and thinking the same
thoughts for the rest of your life allow
your mind to shrink and with it your
world step 3 avoid risk if something's
risky don't do it you don't want to end
up like that one guy who did that thing
and lost everything what was his name
again assume that by avoiding risk you
get to avoid pain believe that the
people who made it big in life made
obvious beneficial decisions with little
perceivable downsides and just wait for
that Crystal Clear opportunity to come
around for you never ask for a raise
tell a risky joke or stand up for what
you think is right never apply for a job
unless you know for sure you're gonna
get it never ask somebody out unless you
know for certain that they're interested
don't put your hand up because your
question might be stupid always wait for
the obvious play because it'll present
itself eventually right
step four overthink let every decision
you make no matter how minute require a
deep brooding think assume that your own
logic is foolproof get lost in the
cobwebs of your own mind divorced from
external scrutiny develop your own
personal theories about everything and
never bounce these ideas off other
people bounce them off yourself step 5
consume always consume more than you
produce keep your brain entertained at
all times not by your own creative
Endeavors obviously but by other people
making stuff fill your mind not with
great works of art or education but with
content willingly subject yourself to
the influence of those who encourage
further consumption constantly stay up
to date with reviews rumors comparisons
motivate yourself not by fostering
virtue but by accumulating objects pay
your dues regular clearly to remain in
this cycle and if consumption becomes
compulsive even better now you don't
have to think about it step six avoid
criticism don't surround yourself with
people who keep you in check challenge
your viewpoints offer differing
perspectives spend time only with those
who think how you think act how you act
constantly judge those who live
differently be quick to shut down any
discussion of matters you're convicted
on especially ones you're emotional
about let your ego blind you from any
real growth go through life believing
that you amazingly have the correct
viewpoint on things politics religion
relationships never learn what it feels
like to have your belief system
challenged because that's uncomfortable
step 7 be secretive never expose your
darker side to anyone for any reason
don't let anybody know about the bad
things you've done or the thing things
you struggle with let your addictions
blossom in secret where they continue to
gain power develop a tendency to hold
your thoughts actions and emotions close
to your chest be proactive in
maintaining a facade of perfection never
let anyone suspect that you could have
flaws or struggles or any kind of normal
human weakness just focus on the ACT The
Show Must Go On let what you do in the
shadows stay there rotting you from the
inside step 8 avoid conflict if
something bothers you don't mention it
if someone wrongs you tell them it's
okay we're good bro never let your
disapproval show on the surface let your
resentment build slowly over time don't
correct mistakes as they happen pretend
not to see them not to hear them after
all talking about anything uncomfortable
is just not something you want to do you
don't want people to think you're a bad
person you're nice and just so easy to
get along along with at least that's
what you hope people say about you let
brief disagreements remain unaddressed
have an elephant in every room let the
unsaid fester and grow evolving
gradually into an overwhelming
resentment just try not to snap because
that makes you look like a bad person
because it's okay if you slowly start to
hate everyone around you as long as they
don't hate you
step 9 play RuneScape step 10 be
pessimistic always find a way to put a
negative spin on things like a demon on
your shoulder convincing you that things
are worse than they actually are
complain compulsively that you have to
go to work instead of that you get to
lament about all these things you have
to do as if you're a child being sent to
bed get so used to complaining that you
can no longer recognize when something
good happens to you everything is bad
everything sucks cling zealously to
narratives that weaken you rather than
Build You Up believe that nothing you
ever do will end up working because
you're playing a losing game then no
habit you try to implement will ever
stick because they never have before
defeat yourself before you even start be
the demon on your own shoulder reflect
only on the negative aspects of yourself
until they're all you can see
swaddle yourself in the despair of
inaction convince yourself that that's
somehow less painful than action
so if you're generally pretty happy and
you want things to just seem a little
less bright then you're in luck because
if you follow this advice you'll
probably ruin the rest of your life
[Music]
a big thank you to athletic greens for
sponsoring this video you guys already
know that ag1 is my favorite supplement
and that's because there's basically no
competing with how easy and simple it is
to drink as well as how good it is for
you and how good it makes me feel
throughout the day packed with over 75
vitamins minerals Whole Food sourced
superfoods and adaptogens in every
single scoop ag1 gives your body
everything it needs to help you feel
focused and energized throughout the day
and unlike so many basic multivitamins
ag-1 has a high degree of
bioavailability which means that your
body can actually absorb it so it can
use it in the most effective way
possible so if you're interested in
joining me in this simple daily habit
that I've been doing for about two years
now than if you use my link in the
description below you'll also get a
year's supply of the vitamin D3 and K2
complex which I also have every single
morning and as well as five ag-1 travel
packs with your first purchase so click
that link to take advantage of that
amazing offer and thanks again to
athletic greens for sponsoring this
video these types of anti-tutorials are
kind of a way to bring these darker
aspects of our psyche and our behaviors
into the light rather than keeping them
in secret and not talking about them it
helps me reflect on my own negative
Tendencies so that I can recognize how
silly they are so if you found this
helpful I would appreciate it if you hit
the like button which will also help
other people see this video and
hopefully it'll help them recognize
their own negative thought patterns and
behaviors if you are lurking here and
you've seen a bunch of my videos before
or if this is the first one consider
hitting the Subscribe button but other
than that thank you so much for watching
and we'll catch you in the next video